[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian sieers ihn
allen einen guten Donnerstagabend dass
ein Gericht der Bundesregierung einen
gewaltigen Strich durch die Rechnung
macht haben wir gerade beim Haushalt
lebt heute erleben wir es schon wieder
diesmal ist es das
Oberverwaltungsgericht
Berlin-Brandenburg das reinörtlich für
die Bundesregierung zuständig ist und
das hat die Regierung heute zu mehr
Klimaschutz verurteilt genauer gesagt zu
einem Sofortprogramm denn die Regierung
verstoße in den Bereichen Verkehr und
Gebäude gegen die Vorgaben des
klimaschutzgesetzes was das jetzt
konkret bedeutet dazu Christoph
Schneider es sind die Bilder die bleiben
entstanden schon vor der Verhandlung
symbolisch werden von den Klägern die
Klimaziele in die Tonne vor dem Gericht
geworfen Kläger sind die Deutsche
Umwelthilfe und der Bund für Umwelt und
Naturschutz sie beklagen dass die
Emissionen im Bereich Gebäude und
Verkehr schon seit Jahren deutlich
überschritten werden die Bundesregierung
hat völlig unzureichende Maßnahmen
vorgelegt um die Klimaziele zu erreichen
und jetzt klafft die Realität mit dem
was in diesen unzureichenden Programmen
steht sogar noch auseinander denn man
hat die Maßnahmen eigentlich abgeschafft
die da drin stehen doch Maßnahmen müssen
sein sagt das Oberverwaltungsgericht
Berlin-Brandenburg und gibt den Klägern
in vollem Umfang Recht verurteilt die
Bundesregierung zur Umsetzung eines
Sofortprogramms das die Einhaltung der
Emissionsmengen in den Sektoren
sicherstellt für die Jahre 2021 und 2022
habe das Umweltbundesamt für die
Bereiche Bau und Verkehr
Überschreitungen der zulässigen Werte
festgestellt danach müssen die
Betroffenen Ministerien sofort Programme
vorlegen und dann greift Paragraph 8 des
klimaschutzgesetzes die Bundesregierung
berätt über die zu ergreifenden
Maßnahmen und beschließt diese schnellst
möglich doch dieser Beschluss sei
ausgeblieben und deswegen müsse das
jetzt umgesetzt werden so die
Richterinnen und Richter am
Oberverwaltungsgericht die Kläger mit
dem Urteil sehr zufrieden Klimaziele
sind nicht verhandelbar sie sind nicht
wie gute Neujahrsvorsätze Jahr für Jahr
schiebbar sondern sie müssen eingehalten
werden wenn sie nicht eingehalten werden
dann muss nachgesteuert werden und das
gilt für die ganze Regierung das gilt
auch für das Verkehrsministerium und das
Ministerium für Bauen und Wohnen
gefordert wird nun eine rasche Umsetzung
des Urteils wir brauchen konkrete
Maßnahmen die die Klimaschutzziele
erreichbar machen keine
Lippenbekenntnisse und irgendwelche
Forschungsaufträge sondern wir brauchen
Fakten und das wä z.B ein Tempolimit auf
den deutschen Straßen das wäre eine
Sanierungsoffensive für die maroden
Schulen und Kindergärten in Deutschland
undten beschleunigter Heizungstausch hin
zu Wärmepumpe aus dem Bau und aus dem
Verkehrsministerium heißt es fast inalt
gleich dass man die Entscheidung
respektiere und nach Vorliegen einer
Begründung prüfen werde eine Revision
beim Bundesverwaltungsgericht ist
möglich die Kläger denken dass der Fall
weitergeht ich rechne erstmal damit dass
die Revision eingelegt wird durch die
Bundesregierung und ich gehe aber auch
fest davon aus dass wir auch vor dem
bundesverwaltungsricht in dem
Revisionsverfahren gewinnen werden nach
dem Urteilsspruch möchten die Grünen
aber erst mit Verkehrsminister Wissing
sprechen wir haben gleich konkret das
Verkehrsministerium adressiert und
gesagt wir haben ja Gesprächsbedarf aber
auch gesprächsbereit
es geht jetzt darum die kurzfristig
wirkende Maßnahmen zu identifizieren und
eben in Geltung zu bringen das
Gerichtsurteil will ja nicht warten
sondern will umgesetzt werden Zeit
gewonnen hätte die Bundesregierung wenn
sie Revision einlegt doch die
Klimaschutzziele dulden eigentlich
keinen
Aufschub ein bisschen Zeit gewinnen wird
die Bundesregierung jetzt denn soeben
kommt die Meldung das
Verkehrsministerium wird Revision
einlegen und wir bleiben noch Moment
beim Klima am Tag an dem die gesamte
Welt zusammenkommt um das Klima auf
unserem Planeten zu retten zumindest ist
das ja die das offizielle Ziel lohnt es
sich mal ein paar ganz nüchterne Zahlen
zu zeigen dieses Jahr dürfte das wärmste
werden seit Beginn der
Industrialisierung das sagt die
normalerweise zurückhaltende
Weltorganisation für
Meteorologie währenddessen machen die
größten Energiekonzerne dieser Welt
nieegekannte Rekordgewinne Shell 40
Milliarden Axon mobile 56 Milliarden
dank des sprudelnden Öl und Gasgeschäfts
und laut Analysten wird dann nur ein
verschwindend geringer Teil dieser
Gewinne in saubere Energie
reinvestiert die Weltklimakonferenz
ausgerechnet im ölemirat Dubai zwischen
Anspruch und Wirklichkeit Elisa mibach
berichtet Dubai Mega City in der Wüste
reich geworden durch Öl und
Austragungsort der diesjährigen
Klimakonferenz ausgerechnet hier und
ausgerechnet in diesem Jahr wird noch
deutlicher was auf dem Spiel steht Wand
der UN
Generalsekretär der Zustand des
Weltklimas im Jahr 2023 ist Glas klar
wir können schon jetzt sagen dass 2023
das wärmste Jahr in der Geschichte der
Menschheit sein wird der mirespiegel hat
Rekordhöhen erreicht und der Anstieg
beschleunigt sich sultanmed soll den
unklimagipfel zum Erfolg führen
gleichzeitig ist der Chef des
staatlichen Ölriesen adnok und der
Konzern will sein Öl und Gasgeschäft
noch ausbauen dabei ist alterbär
diplomatisches Geschick entscheidend
weiß Christoph bals der alle 28
Klimakonferenzen beobachtet hat das ist
ein Manager der versucht das effektiv zu
Ergebnissen zu
führen der wird auch einiges positive
dabei sein ich befürchte aber dass
gerade an den Knackpunkten wo es drum um
geht die fossilen Energien jetzt massiv
runterzufahren hier Spiele gespielt
werden um das de facto zu verhindern und
dass das allenfalls auf dem Papier
erreicht wird eine Überraschung sorgte
aber heute schon für Jubel der auf der
vergangenen Klimakonferenz beschlossene
Fond für Schäden und Verluste wird
gefüllt reiche Staaten die den
Klimawandel verursacht haben geben Geld
an ärmere Länder die am härtesten an den
Klimafolgen Leiden der Fond startet
durch eine Allianz der Emirate und
Deutschland die jeweils 100 Millionen
Dollar zusagen weitere Staaten folgen
mit kleineren Beiträgen aljaber ist
stolz wir haben heute Geschichte
geschrieben denn zum ersten Mal wurde
eine Entscheidung am ersten Tag einer
Klimakonferenz
angenommen und vielleicht ein
Präzedenzfall dass Reiche
Schwellenländer wie die anderen
Golfstaaten und China in Zukunft auch in
den Fond einzahlen bislang haben sie
sich immer geweigert dass mehr Geld
gebraucht wird sagen Experten und die
vom Klimawandel am meisten
en im Pazifik kostet die Umsiedlung
eines Dorfs das von der Klimakrise
betroffen ist und 100 Millionen Dollar
und das ist nur ein Dorf auf einer Insel
im
Pazifik gerade das so viele Perspektiven
der Welt hier zumindest aufeinander
treffen macht diese Konferenzen trotz
allem so besonders damit ein einindämmen
der Klimakrise aber ausgerechnet in der
ölmetropole Dubai beschlossen werden
kann braucht es noch einige Erfolge und
Überraschung
Jennifer morgan ist die
Sonderbeauftragte für internationale
Klimapolitik im Auswärtigen Amt Frau
Morgan guten Abend nach
Dubai guten Abend 2015 war die
Klimakonferenz von Paris hat damals als
Ziel ausgegeben 1,5° Erderwärmung nicht
mehr jetzt 8 Jahre später Konferenz in
Dubai und die Welt steuert auf 3° zu
welchen Wert haben solche
Klimakonferenzen
ja vor Paris fahr der Welt auf ein Fahrt
nach 4° temperaturerhörung so der Paris
Abkommen hat schon was gebracht also
alle Länder haben jetzt nationale Ziele
aber wir sind zu weit weg von von dieses
Ziel aber diese Konferenzen sind wichtig
weil wir sitzen alle hier um Tisch mit
den verletzbarsten Länder es ist der
Moment wo wir zusammenkommen können um
dieses Problem zu lösen aber es ist
nicht das einzige was machen in unserer
Klimapolitik aber schon heutzutage in
eine multilaterale Setzung wie diese
ist sehr hilfreich ja schon die
Klimakonferenz in Paris hat eigentlich
alle Staaten der Welt eingebunden und
zwar völkerrechtlich verpflichtend ist
es dann am Ende aber doch so dass die
Aussicht auf kurzfristige Gewinne und
Wohlstand doch viel viel mächtiger
sind ich glaube es gibt verschiedene
Interesse das stimmt also was wir sehen
jetzt in diesem Moment was eigentlich so
eine krasse mente in der Klimadebatte
ist ist dass wir sind in einer
Klimakrise mit dieser Auswirkung die
sind findet statt weltweit aber wir sind
auch in einem Moment der Chance eine
Wendepunkt in erneuerbare Energie und
Energieeffizienz wo wir wissen wenn wir
jetzt die richtige Signale geben wenn
wir jetzt richtig investieren dann
werden die Temperatur unter dieser 1,5°
Z bleiben und die Emissionen würden
runterkommen und da ist auch wichtig
weil da kommen Jobs da kommt Wachstum
und hier sind viele Länder daran
interessiert aus Afrika sudamericaa und
so weiter ja sie sagen man muss da
richtig investieren aktuell passiert
aber doch genau das Gegenteil BP z.B der
Energiekonzern korrigiert seine
Klimaziele und zwar nach unten und
investiert wird eben nur zu ganz
verschwindend kleinen Teilen in in
Zukunfts in klimaneutrale Technologien
und zum zum großen Teil zum allergrößten
Teil in Öl und Gas also in fossile
Energien das passiert Frau morgen genau
das Gegenteil aktuell von dem was sie
gerade
erzählen es kommt darf an wo man
hinguckt also die Internationale
Energieagentur hat gefunden dass mehr
Investition in solar und erneuerbare
jetzt stattfinden über fossilen über
Kohle Öl und Gas ja was die
Ölunternehmen machen das ist kurzfristig
gedacht aber wir brauchen eine
verantwortliche Politik wir brauchen
verantwortliche Unternehmen und wo ich
eigentlich hingucken sind die
Mittelstandsunternehmen unsere deutsche
Stahlunternehmen die
dekarbonisieren sie sind dran sie
verstehen dass wir sind in diese Krise
aber wir sind auch kurz in diese
Wendezeit und damit kommt auch chanceen
was ist von einer Weltklimakonferenz zu
halten deren Präsident gleichzeitig Chef
des staatlichen Ölkonzerns der Emir Rate
ist diese Klimakonferenzen haben diese
koppräsidentfunktion und diese Funktion
ist wichtig absolut weil letztendlich
werden wir diese koppräsident messen
gegen was er hier schafft also was sind
die Taten was sind die Erfolge und da
sind wir jetzt hier wirklich drin also
heute war eine gute Start es gibt kurz
unterbrechen darf kann er überhaupt
etwas schaffen wenn er gleichzeitig Chef
eines Ölkonzerns ist
es ja was er bis jetzt gezeigt hat ist
dass er wächst in diese Rolle als
koppräsident das
er muss natürlich total achtsam sein er
muss zeigen dass er an die kleine
inselstatt zuhört er muss zeigen dass er
bereit ist die AktivistInnen hier das
Wort auch zu geeben und wenn er das
nicht tut dann wird seine eigene
Glaubwürdigkeit natürlich runtergehen im
Moment sind alle eigentlich dabei die
Lösungen hier zu zu finden das ist das
ist der Fokus die Organisation
Greenpeace von der sie selbst kommen
Frau Morgan sie waren da mal die Chefin
die sagt wir haben große Sorge dass die
Konferenz eine Plattform sein wird für
die Interessen der Öl und Gasindustrie
dass da also sowas wie wie Greenwashing
in ganz großem Ausmaß stattfindet lässt
sich das überhaupt noch
verhindern ja wir müssen total Asam sein
und wir müssen auch die Transparenz in
diese Grenzen in diese hier in Dubai ist
sehr wichtig wie die Entscheidung
getroffen sein werden wer ist da am
Tisch also wir sehen hier viele
verschiedene Akteuren Fossil Unternehmen
aber auch NGOs Wissenschaftler aber wie
dieser Prozess läuft das beobachten wir
ganz genau auch dass es sehr inklusive
ist für NGOs und anderen sod dass eine
Interesse nicht über anderen eigentlich
mehr Macht hat jetzt ist ja Deutschland
sie vertreten die Bundesregierung vor
Ort Deutschland alles andere als
Vorreiter gerade heute hat ein Gericht
die Bundesregierung verurteilt wegen zu
wenig Klimaschutz deutschland müsse
jetzt sofort Programme auflegen in den
Bereichen Gebäuden und
Verkehr ja es ist klar was was ich finde
was diese Regierung geschafft hat in
diese letzte zwei Jahren B sind 80% der
Weg zu unserer Ziel aber es ist K dass
wir mehr machen müssen D in der
Verkehrssektor und Gebäudesektor mussen
wir nachhollen was
hei mus jetzt passieren nach dieser
Gerichtsentscheidung also diese
Gerichtsentscheidung natürlich wird
gepruft also ich glaube die Regierung
ist sehr bewüst auch von unserer
unabhängige Expertengruppe die eine auch
so eine Studien veröffentlicht hat d es
gibt Lücke aber wir sind wirklich mrin
wir sind auf den Weg und hier kann ich
sagen in Dubai ist Deutschland als
Vorreiter wahrgenommen weil wir setzen
um aber gibt noch mehr zu tun das ist
absolut richtig sagt Jennifer Morgan die
Sonderbeauftragte für internationale
Klimapolitik im Auswärtigen Amt Frau
morgen danke schön für das Gespräch nach
Dubai vielen Dank und das haben wir aus
Termingründen vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet der Blick auf die Lage in
Nahost heute ganz vor bei dir Hanna in
der Nachrichtenübersicht beim Anschlag
in Jerusalem sind drei Israelis getötet
worden sechs weitere wurden verletzt am
frühen Morgen hatten zwei Palästinenser
an einer Bushaltestelle das Feuer
eröffnet zu der Tat bekannte sich
anschließend die Hamas unterdessen gehen
die Verhandlungen über eine Verlängerung
der Feuerpause weiter um den Austausch
weiterer Geiseln und Gefangener zu
ermöglichen auch US Außenminister
Blinken der heute in Israel eintraf
sprach sich für eine Fortsetzung aus die
aktuelle Pause läuft morgen früh aus
heute wurden wieder israelische Geiseln
von der Hamas
freigelassen der Bundestag hat in erster
Lesung über das neue Gesetz zur
schnelleren Rückführung von illegalen
Migranten debattiert
bundesinnenministerin fäser verteidigte
ihr Vorhaben das unter anderem vorsieht
dass Straftäter schneller und
konsequenter abgeschoben werden zudem
soll der ausreisewahrsam verlängert
werden die Union kriier das Gesetz da es
nicht weit genug gehe Teile der Grünen
befürchten das Gegenteil die Abgeordnete
Polat sieht Eingriffe in elementare
Grundrechte weiteres Thema war der
Gesetzentwurf zur schnelleren
Einbürgerung im Terrorprozess um die
rechtsextreme Gruppe s sind heute teils
langjährige Haftstrafen gegen die
Mitglieder verhängt worden der
Rädelsführer der Gruppe Werner S wurde
vom Oberlandesgericht Stuttgart zu 6
Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt neun weitere
Angeklagte erhielten ebenfalls
mehrjährige Haftstrafen zum Teil auf
Bewährung die Gruppe s plante laut
Anklage einen Umsturz der politischen
Ordnung in Deutschland und Anschläge auf
Moscheen der Oberste Gerichtshof in
Russland hat die lgbtq plus Bewegung als
extremistisch eingestuft und ihre
Aktivitäten in Russland verboten das
Gericht folgte damit einem Antrag des
Justizministeriums Amnesty International
warnte vor dass die rechte schwuler
lesbischer und anderer querer Menschen
in Russland damit noch weiter
eingeschränkt
werden auf dem deutschen Arbeitsmarkt
ist auch im Monat November die sonst
übliche Herbstbelebung ausgeblieben
Grund ist die anhaltende
Konjunkturflaute laut der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit waren im November
2606 000 Menschen ohne Job das sind 1000
weniger als im Oktober aber
172 000 mehr als im November des
vergangenen Jahres die Arbeitslosenquote
sinkt auf
5,6% von einer Weltkonferenz bei der die
Frage im Raum steht ob sie scheitert
haben wir schon berichtet es gibt heute
noch eine zweite die ihr Scheitern ganz
unmittelbar vor Augen hat so ist es mal
losgegangen im Kalten Krieg ein bisschen
mehr Sicherheit Helsinki in Schwarz-Weiß
der Bundeskanzler hieß Schmidt der SED
Chef honeker der Präsident Ford daraus
wurde die weltweit größte regionale
Sicherheitsorganisation die Rüstung in
Schach hielt und Vertrauen schaffte gut
der Name ist sperrig
OSZE aber ihre Arbeit wäre gerade jetzt
wichtiger denn je wäre denn das Treffen
heute in Mazedonien gleicht einer Art
Showdown russland versucht die OSZE lahm
zu legen und könnte damit Erfolg haben
Andreas
kün es ist erste Mal dass die
Wagenkolonne des russischen
Außenministers wieder durch ein NATO und
EU Beitrittsland fährt und das
nordmazedonische Fernsehen überträgt
jeden Meter im zweiten Jahr des Krieges
versucht Serge lavrov zurückzukehren auf
die roten Teppiche auch die des Westens
als wir fragen wann Russland den Krieg
beendet macht lavrov den
lavrov schöne Haarfarbe hat die Frau da
antwortet Moskaus Auen Minister niemand
lacht auch die Frau da
nicht ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll
das Thema ist so wichtig und wir haben
eine Frage dazu dass er da einen auf
fröhliche Stimmung macht dazu fällt mir
gar nichts
ein der Stuhl der Ukraine bleibt heute
leer auch Polen und die baltischen
Staaten wollen lavrov nicht auf einer
Tagung sondern vor dem Strafgerichtshof
sehen die deutsche Außenministerin ist
inje will die OSZE nicht Russlands
Angriffen überlassen lavrov blockiert
fast alles mit seinem Veto den Haushalt
den Vorsitz den OSZE Alltag aber wenn
ihn jemand kritisiert geht er raus und
da Russland heute hier im Saal ist der
Außenminister offensichtlich wie auch
bei anderen Sitzungen nur wenn er selber
spricht aber nicht um anderen zuzuhören
sage ich an dieser Stelle noch einmal
deutlich stoppen Sie diesen Krieg der
auch ein Krieg auf genau diese
Organisation ist es wird eine
bemerkenswerte Sitzung ein Redner nach
dem anderen ein Land nach dem anderen
fordert Russland zum Rückzug aus der
Ukraine
auf Krieg und Zerstörung sind Russlands
Wahl man muss daran erinnern dass
Russland diesen Krieg jederzeit beenden
kann stoppen Sie
was unerklärlich ist für dass es keinen
Grund gibt Stärke ist nicht zu zeigen
dass sie stärker sind sondern dass sie
das Leid von Millionen
beenden wir fordern Russland auf ziehen
sie sich sofort und bedingungslos zurück
und lassen Sie alle Gefangenen frei
inklusive der drei OSZE
Mitarbeiter lavrov kommt nur kurz und
nur für seine Rede in den Saal das
neonaziregime in Kiev sagt er wolle
alles russische ausrotten und der Westen
Hetze es
auf Organisation steht am Rande des
Abgrunds und es ist die Frage ob es noch
lohnt Anstrengungen zu unternehmen um
sie
wiederzubeleben dann fährt lavrov zurück
in sein Hotel ein Land hat das Überleben
der OSZE gefährdet die anderen 56 werden
sie retten
müssen die signa immobilienholding des
österreichischen Milliardärs Rene Benko
hat die größte Firmenpleite in
Österreichs Geschichte hingelegt wir
haben das gestern hier ausführlich
besprochen en da war bereits klar das
zieht weite Kreise hat gravierende
Folgen auch für uns hier in Deutschland
und die ersten zeigen sich bereits jetzt
Hanna na du sagst es gestern das Beben
die sign Holding ist insolvent heute
folgte dann die Tochter SportScheck und
erklärte auch wir sind zahlungsunfähig
das meht die fragen wie es nun
weitergeht auch mit anderen Teilen der
signnergruppe Frank betmann und da haben
die Städte jetzt schon angekündigt dass
sie mitreden wollen wenn es etwa um
Galeria kstadt Kaufhof geht genau die
Städte fordern dass sie aktiv in die
Gespräche eingebunden werden
perspektivisch wolle man sich sogar den
Zugriff auf einzelne Immobilien in den
Innenstädten sichern doch das ist
Zukunftsmusik heute hat erstmal die
Schweizer handelstochter der Signa
Holding zu der auch Galeria gehört
Gläubigerschutz beantragt mit dem Ziel
dass das Warenhausgeschäft eben nicht
mit in die Pleite gerissen wird das
Weihnachtsgeschäft jedenfalls ist nicht
in Gefahr es soll so ist aus
Unternehmenskreisen zu hören besser als
erwartet angelaufen sein danach aber
droht Ungemach mit 50 Millionen Euro
rechnet der Warenhauskonzern im Februar
von der Mutter der signner Holding ob
das Geld nach der Insolvenz nun aber
noch kommt ist mehr als unsicher hat
Galeria karstadtkaufof denn irgendeinen
Plan B ja man hat einen faustfand das
sind die sehr hohen Mieten die man
quartalsweise in Millionenhöhe an die
sinerholding abführen muss da prüft man
offenbar gerade ob man die einbehält
damit das Geld in der Kasse bleibt oder
aber es findet sich ein neuer Investor
der bei Galeria einsteigt das dürfte
sich allerdings sehr schwierig gestalten
nicht zuletzt weil kritiker behaupten
das Warenhausgeschäft in dieser Form
habe keine Zukunft vielen Dank Frank für
deine
Einschätzung zum Fußball in der Europa
League traf der SC Freiburg am Abend auf
olympicos pereus und hatte ohne Frage
einigen Grund zum Jubeln Freiburg siegte
mit 5:0 die Mannschaft steht damit
bereits vor dem letzten Gruppenspiel
sicher in der K
Phase die Deutschen biathlonmänner haben
beim ersten Staffelrennen der Weltcup
saaison Platz 3 belegt im schwedischen
Östersund konnten David Zobel Philip
nafrad Benedikt doll und Johannes kühn
dank einer starken Laufleistung 16
Nachlader und eine Strafrunde
kompensieren und so den Podestplatz
sichern es gewann Norwegen vor
Frankreich seine Stimme gilt als
einzigartig seine Poesie als
leidenschaftlich er war aber auch für
seinen Alkohol und Drogenkonsum bekannt
nun ist Shane mcgowen Sänger der
anglo-irischen Punk Folk Band The Pokes
gestorben mcowen der die meisten Lieder
der Band selbst verfasste schrieb über
irische Kultur und irischen
Nationalismus und mischte traditionelle
Klänge mit
punkelementen Berühmtheit erlangte er
vor allem mit einer weihnachtsballade
der Fairy Tale of New York Shane mcgen
wurde 65 Jahre
[Musik]
alt sie mich fragen die absolut beste
Musik für Herbst und
Winter und jetzt ein frange der zum
Weltbürger wurde mit 15 musste er
fliehen vor den Nazis seine stad fürt
hat er dennoch Zeit Lebens nicht
vergessen können und so ist Henry
Kissinger der jetzt im Alter von 100
Jahren gestorben ist auch ein Symbol für
Versöhnung nach unvorstellbarem grauen
der Mann der zu einer schillernden Figur
der Weltpolitik wurde hat noch erlebt
dass die Spielvereinigung vit Mal
Deutscher Fußballmeister
war und er ist immer wieder dorthin
zurückgekehrt Oberbürgermeister Thomas
jung erinnert sich genau das ein
jahrhundertpersönlichkeit Weltpolitik
betreibt mit Mao und allen bedeutenden
führen der Welt kommuniziert aber die
Heimatstadt die Geburtsstadt nie
vergisst obwohl er von dort vertrieben
wurde immer wieder herherkommt und die
Krönung war tatsächlich hunder
Geburtstag New York London für das waren
die Orte der Feier New York London F F
wurde nicht vergessen F war glaube ich
emotional sogar vielleicht am
wichtigsten K der Außenminister aus
Deutschland gefeiert und verachtet ein
Diplomat mit Machtinstinkt der nachruof
von
elmthevsen sie feiern seinen hundersten
geburtstag mit ihm und Henry Kissinger
autet sich augenzwinkernd in seiner
Heimatstadt führt als bekennender Franke
und ich hoffe dass ich dass sie mir
nachher sagen werden dass ich einen
etwas fränkischen Akzent
über die Jahre bewahrt
habe geboren wird Heinrich Alfred
Kissinger 1923
entführt 1938 flieht seine jüdische
Familie vor den
Nazis 6 Jahre später kehrt er als
US-Soldat zurück ist beteiligt am
Wiederaufbau der Zivilverwaltung ein
Brückenbauer später wird der Bürger der
Stadt führt unsere beiden Völker sind
vom bitteren Konflikt zum Frieden und
vom Frieden zur Versöhnung und zu
gemeinsamen Streben geschritten
Präsident Nixon holt den Historiker und
Politikwissenschaftler ins Zentrum der
Macht Kissinger mischt brilante Analyse
mit gnadenlosem Pragmatismus ein
Realpolitiker der alle Ideologien
verachtet unter seinem Einfluss beginnen
die Supermächte im Kalten Krieg mit der
Entspannungspolitik auch die deutsche
Ostpolitik liegt ganz auf seiner
linieind aber
keinb seine Unterschrift besiegelt das
Ende des Vietnamkriegs Jahres später als
es möglich gewesen wäre sagen Kritiker
Jahre mit hunderttausenden Toten
trotzdem bekommt Kissinger den
Friedensnobelpreis auch dafür bnt er mit
seiner Geheimdiplomatie den Weg Richard
Nixons historischer Besuch bei Maung
Tauwetter in den en zwischen China und
den
USA auch nach seiner Amtszeit sucht
Kissinger das Gespräch mit unliebsamen
Machthabern im ukrainekrieg verurteilt
er die russische Aggression und gibt
weisen Rat für die
Zukunft die Ukraine sollte dann auch
Mitglied der NATO werden um sie vor
künftigen russischen Angriffen zu
[Musik]
schützen Fan des Fußballclubs geuter
fürt bedeutender Europäer und
Amerikaner auch umstritten ja aber vor
allem eines ein legendärer
[Musik]
Diplomat so und jetzt gleich im ZDF
Maybritt ner stellt eine ihrer berühmten
donnerstagsfragen Ampel in Notlage ohne
Geld ohne Vertrauen Antworten werden
unter anderem die Partei Chefs von CDU
und SPD jetzt gleich hier bei uns nach
uns viel mehr ja und gegen 030 Uhr
meldet sich hier Laura barnck mit
unserem heute journal Update wir sind
morgen wieder für Sie da und zwar sehr
gerne für heute ein angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
tschüss
guten Abend heute Nacht droht
gefährlicher Glatteisregen hier am
Alpenrand weiter Richtung Norden kommt
eher Schnee aus den Wolken und über den
Schneeflächen im Nordosten wird es sehr
kalt da sinken die Temperaturen zum Teil
unter - 10° am oberrein liegen die
Tiefsttemperaturen um 3° morgen gibt's
höchstemperaturen um den Gefrierpunkt am
oberrein werden 5° erreicht und auch
morgen Vormittag sollten Sie sich noch
auf gefährlich glatte Straßen und
Gehwege vor allen Dingen im Süden von
baden-württenemberg und Bayern
einstellen Richtung Franken und
Thüringen gibt's etwas Schnee sonst wird
das ein freundlicher Freitag mit einigen
Schneeschauern an der Nordseeküste und
Ostseeküste der windnter zuu kommt aus
nördlichen Richtungen am Samstag ziehen
die Schneewolken ostwärts ab Sonntag zum
ersten Advent geht's dann häufig Sonne
über den Schneeflächen und jetzt weiten
wir den
Blick denn heute ist ja die
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai gestartet
viele Menschen denken wenn wir den
Treibhaus gasausstoß senken z.B
halbieren sinken die Temperaturen wieder
ein Trugschluss stellen wir uns die
Lufthülle als Badewanne vor in die immer
mehr CO2 fließt die Wanne ist gerade so
groß dass ihr CO2 Gehalt einer
weltweiten Temperaturerhöhung von 1,5°
entspricht gemäß Pariser Klimaabkommen
sie füllt sich weiter auch wenn wir nur
noch halb so viel CO2 zuführen wie
bisher irgendwann läuft sie über und wir
reißen die Marke von 1, 5° globaler
Temperaturerhöhung das verhindern wir
nur indem wir die CO2 Zufuhr komplett
stoppen guten Abend